لذلك يوجد هنا أكثر من 80 صفحة
تشكل ما يسمى رسميًا
بالاتفاقية الاقتصادية والتجارية بين
الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
وجمهورية الصين الشعبية ،
وتعرف هذه أيضًا بالمرحلة الأولى من صفقة التجارة بين الولايات المتحدة والصين والتي
تأتي بعد 18 شهرًا  من
وارد التجارة الذي طال بين
البلدين ، أكبر
اقتصادين في العالم ، الولايات المتحدة والصين ،
يصوران هذا على أنه فوز ، وقد حدث هذا بالطبع
في واشنطن العاصمة
، ووصفه الرئيس دونالد ترامب بأنه
أكبر شيء يحدث
بين البلدين.  الدول التي تقول إن
هذا سيسمح بمزيد من
التعاون الآن ، تختلف التفاصيل فيما يتعلق
بالموضوعات التي تغطيها ، وأعني أنها
واسعة النطاق تمامًا إذا كنت ستنتقل
من عمليات الشراء الضخمة التي
وعدت الصين بإجراءها منا  السلع
التي تبلغ قيمتها حوالي 200 مليار دولار والتي تغطي
الزراعة وصناعة الخدمات
بالإضافة إلى الطاقة ، بل إنها
تدخل في تفاصيل أخرى مثل
السلع المقلدة والحماية من
حقوق الطبع والنشر حتى تعتقد أن هذا محددًا هو
سلامة الأغذية وضمان أن حليب الأطفال
يتم تصديره من الولايات المتحدة.
في الصين ستحافظ
الآن على معايير معينة ، ليوها نائب رئيس مجلس الدولة الذي
يمثل الوفد الصيني
يستحضر كلمات الرئيس شي جين بينغ
التي قرأها رسالة أظهرت بشكل أساسي
أن الرئيس شي كان فخورًا بهذه
اللحظة وشعر أن هذا بالمثل
كان ناجحًا وقال إنه  سيؤدي
إلى تعاون أكبر بين
البلدين والقول إن هذا مكسب ليس
لنا فقط  ليس فقط بالنسبة للصين ولكن
أيضًا بالنسبة للعالم ، ولكن من الجدير بالذكر أيضًا
أن الرئيس شي قال إنه
يأمل في أن يتم
التعامل مع الشركات الصينية بشكل عادل للمضي قدمًا ، كما
قال إنه يدعم التبادلات في
الجامعات والمؤسسات البحثية
للمضي قدمًا لذا يبدو أنه
استغل اللحظة لإظهار أن الولايات المتحدة والصين
لا ينبغي أن ينفصلا ، بل ينبغي بدلاً من ذلك
الاستمرار في العمل معًا ،
وبثت وسائل الإعلام الحكومية الصينية هذا على الهواء مباشرة حيث
حدث هذا التوقيع في
منتصف الليل هنا 2:00 صباحًا ومع ذلك
شعروا بالرغبة في ذلك  كان يستحق البث إلى
جمهورية الشعب ، فإنه يدل على أنهم
يشعرون أن هذا مثل
الحكمة هو حركة إيجابية
وأنهم يأملون في المضي قدمًا الآن في
المرحلة الثانية من المرجح أن تتضمن المرحلة الثانية المزيد من
القضايا الهيكلية التي يمكن أن تكون
أكثر إشكالية قليلاً في القدوم إلى  بل إن
اتفاقًا بشأن الرئيس ترامب قد
اقترح أنه قد يتجاوز
انتخابات 2020 ديفيد كلفر سي إن إن
بكين